[Music]
knife making is almost meditative for me
there's a lot of passion behind it
there's a lot of hard work behind it and
it's not just something that you kind of
just brush off like oh this is just a
knife
[Music]
people hands touch this knife people
pour their passion and their soul inside
of these products
the art of blacksmithing has a very long
history
our notion of what it means to be
civilized is to have metallurgy to have
the ability to transform the natural
world
when somebody used my knife i wanted to
see damn
golly this is a bad ass knife
come here let me show you something
well let me tell you what quentin
middleton does i make knives for a
living
who knew
[Music]
i am from saint stephen south carolina
that's maybe about an hour away from
charleston south carolina we're in
basically my backyard
this is my studio this is where it all
goes down where every last one of my
knives is made
[Music]
why does quentin middleton make knives
because i love it it's just a voice love
from watching fantasy movies like star
wars he-man conan like it just piqued my
imagination
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've watched him go from making kung fu
weapons out of lawn mower blades
to chef's knives to being a a serious
businessman like a force to be reckoned
with
i love color i love pops of color i love
the reds the blues the greens that's my
personality and i like my knives to look
sexy
the knife we'll be making today will be
an 8 inch chef knife it will be damascus
damascus steel is a set of techniques
that involve the layering of iron upon
iron upon iron creating this more
complex and more durable structure
i will be using two types of steel it
basically is going to give you contrast
between shiny and dark you will see a
bunch of swirls in it that's what make
it pretty
first i'm measuring each one of these a
piece of steel each one of them is cut
at five inches
and then i'm chopping up in the chop saw
i take it next to my grinder
and i'm cleaning the surface of the
billets so when i put it in the forge it
has a clean surface to adhere to
i'm going to stack about 10 layers
and i'm going to weld it together
[Music]
now we're going to put it into a forge
and the forage is about 2300 degrees and
basically that's not mulching but very
close so i needed to stick to each other
i'm looking for a certain particular
color the color i'm looking for is like
a bright yellowish orange so once it
reaches the the color i'm looking for
it's time to pull it out because i don't
want it to burn or melt
next we're going to use the hydraulic
press and we're going to compress it so
this is now kneading the steel like
dough and i'm not going to initially
just chomp down on it i'm doing light
touches
and once we do that and we get a long
enough piece we're going to cut it in
half
[Music]
the piece that i cut off i'm going to
stack it to the other piece building up
those layers
and we're going to do the same thing
again put it in the forge heat it up
draw it out on the hydraulic press
and i'm gonna cut it again
so basically now we have a a great
starting point to what the knife is
gonna look like
historically blacksmithing played an
important role in the formation of
african-american identity
during the transatlantic slave trade
which carried
more than 12 million africans many
hundreds and even thousands of
blacksmiths were among them
they came with their knowledge of
ironworking and smelting and forging and
their ritual power
they were remarkable individuals and
they became leaders in the community
so on plantations they might have been
responsible for shoeing horses for
keeping the operations of the industrial
complex going they not only forged
iron shackles but they forged the
weapons that account for the resistance
to slavery for example we know that
african blacksmiths played a tremendous
role in the haitian revolution
sometime around the late 19th century
science
began to transform and professionalize
iron working
in that process many african americans
were left out of the picture they were
being excluded and discriminated against
in the workplace
they still played a critical role and
their labor and their expertise was
really important to
the rise of many different industries
today blacksmithing has become an
important art form and african americans
have a very important role in the
contemporary community of artisans
they have persisted in part because they
stayed longer in rural communities
so african-american blacksmiths have
really
remained critical to the persistence of
these techniques of forging by hand
exquisitely beautiful objects out of
iron
[Music]
so next i'll be grinding the knife to
shape
i take a template and i lay it on to the
billet and then now i'm cutting the
excess away so basically the whole
perimeter of the knife
[Music]
[Applause]
after i cut the excess away now it's
time to normalize it and heat treat it
we did all this hard work in the
beginning to get the width and the
thickness we want so it has a lot of
stress inside of it so i need to
basically massage
basically you need to go into the sauna
so that's what normalizing is heating it
to its critical temperature and for this
instance is about 1500 degrees
and then i have to quickly dip it in oil
this process is called quenching
this process is allowing the grain
structure inside the steel to realign
and mesh together and i need it to stay
that way so that's what the quenching
process does
now since i quenched it in oil this
knife is so brittle that i can take a
hammer or throw it on the ground it will
shatter in a thousand pieces
so now i need to put in the oven at 400
degrees for two hours span allowing it
to soften just slightly but still be
hard enough to hold an edge and that is
the key point of
a knife it needs to be able to hold an
edge and stay sharp for a very long time
as a child i was very adventurous i was
a loner
i would play in the woods make my own
bow and arrows sling shots i would take
tubing off my swing set and flatten it
with a hammer and make my own sword
there are not many
probably five or six black knife makers
that i can think of
right now
and it was very hard
because it's a white dominated area and
a lot of people didn't want to teach me
starting out
[Music]
i worked at a local mall and i sold
knives and cigars and swords and a man
came in one day his name is jason knight
clinton was behind the counter and he
knew what he was talking about he knew
all the knives he knew what they were
made out of he knew where they were from
he was very interested in the whole idea
of making knives
and he started telling me that he make
knives for a living and as a 17 year old
boy like my eyes like brighten up like
can you teach me
he's making me nervous
i'm a teacher
gotta make sure i do it right
he'd come to my shop and he would show
me what he made and i would give him
some pointers and then he would go back
and work on that again
and uh one day he
[Music]
he came over and he said god told me to
make chef's knives
i was following suit behind jason making
hunting knives swords and the fantasy
movie swords
and then i had a dream
i'm very big in my faith
and the holy spirit told me plainly make
chef knives
and i woke up i think
that makes sense
probably within eight months every chef
in charleston had a chef's knife in
their hands that quentin had the guts to
go out and say i want to let you try
this knife out and see what you think
and he built a whole business around
that
that's the exciting thing that's the fun
thing is to watch something grow from a
little seed and watch it become awesome
i just i love the guy he's my friend
he's my brother i want him to be the
rock star knife maker that he is
so now next what we'll be doing we
finish uh doing the bevel grinding
basically getting it to a sharp point
so i'm grinding it from the thickness
that it is now to basically down to zero
on the edge
i don't measure anything so it's all
about field i've been doing this 18
years and it's muscle memory i'm
constantly checking it making sure that
my grinds are straight and consistent uh
make sure that everything flows well
and then i will be putting it inside a
developer
right now it looks silver so you really
don't see the the patterns yet until i
put it in the spheric chloride
now you're about to see what we all
wanted to see the pattern the twists and
the turns and the curls and the swooshes
and
doesn't it look sexy
now here comes the heavy part for me
adding the handle
the handle material is going to be
oak but what's so special about this oak
this oak came from a plantation this
plantation is called middleton's place
we are currently
at middleton's place plantation
maybe 20 minutes away from downtown
charleston
and my last name is middleton so
you know the deal
[Music]
my ancestors were here
they
worked this land
they bled here they died here
they were beaten here they may were hung
here
this oak tree is basically a live oak or
enchanted angel oak
this tree has been here since slavery
time
the directors over middleton place
plantation
we had this little project i made some
oyster nights for them and they were
kind enough to gift me some of the wood
that fell off this tree
and that's the handler i use for this
knife
what i want to do
is build off broken pieces
i'm taking something that's
barbaric that's
a stain on america's history
and building off of that in my own way
this wood is basically a block and i'm
going to cut it to shape
i want to create a chemical and a
mechanical bond the chemical bond is the
epoxy
the mechanical bond is a screw and i can
screw the handle to the blade
after we let the glue dry we will grind
the perimeter of the handle
basically i'm just trying to get that
coke bottle shape i just want it to be
smooth i want it to be almost like a car
the lines need to fit they need to flow
just right
and i want to add a sealer
now you're about to see the rings of the
oak you can almost count and see how old
this tree really was
now it's time to sharpen the knife and
i'm paying very close attention on the
angle making sure that it's not too
steep or not too shallow
now you're seeing how sexy this knife
looked i am proud to put my name on it
so now i'm going to be putting my makers
mark on it my logo i use a laser
engraver and we'll be allowing the laser
to engrave my logo inside this knife
growing up
my granddad told me your name is
everything
to put your name on something that means
you stand by it just like your handshake
you stand by your handshake
[Music]
now it's time to box it up
wrap it up and ship it out
since this one is so special and this is
so much emotion inside this one
it'll probably be around two thousand
dollars
[Music]
people ask me a lot how long does it
take to make a knife
i answered that two ways
if i have everything
on hand i can make that knife in eight
hours
and the second way i answer that is kind
of snobbish
18 years
and you got you have to look off at it
[Laughter]
the time and the mistakes that i made
and all the blood sweat and tears i put
into my craft it feels like second
nature to me
[Music]
growing up as a boy you never really
hear like you're doing a good job
as a southern man you more like go to
school go to work work hard provide for
your family
but to build this knife in honor of my
ancestors they're saying job well done
i've built my brain i've built this
company
and what i'm hearing in my spirit what
i'm hearing in my inner man is saying
i'm proud of you
that's what i feel
[Music]
you